[Music]
hi i'm marie vandetuli i'm a senior
statistical programmer at fred hutch
in the statistical center for hiv aids
research and prevention
at our studio account 2020 my colleague
ellis hughes shared technical details
demonstrating how our organization is
tackling the challenge of software
validation for our packages
it's now a year later we have three
packages released and are tackling the
extended challenge of ensuring that our
entire verse is fit for purpose as an
integrated unit
today i'll be sharing my thoughts
regarding multi-package development in
the pharma environment
my first recommendation is to set the
team up for success by getting
infrastructure in order
moving away from historical validation
practices means updating or generating
new sops another area for infrastructure
support is to establish
common development guidelines that get
shared across all packages
this is especially important if packages
are implementing legacy code
that was previously siloed the ultimate
benefit however
is code portability within the overall
project my next recommendation is the
need to address development from an
empathy perspective
at sharp we observe four distinct roles
one user's rapidly processing data
these would be primarily statistical
programmers
two data analysts reviewing code for
context these would be individuals who
need to be able to rapidly assess
contacts from function names alone three
stakeholders interacting with functions
solely from the package validation
report
so this could be someone involved in
writing specifications and test cases
but aren't participating in coding
activity
four package developers and maintainers
who seek to eliminate duplication or
re-implementation with package updates
now one common need that transcends all
of these user groups is to have a
vocabulary which allows us to place
functions within the larger context of
assay-specific data processing tasks
that is we want to survey what has been
implemented
filter either by assay or task and call
up help page documentation on demand
so this is actually reference to
schneiderman's information seeking
mantra which is typically cited in
visualization literature in this context
we are treating the function
names as the identifying handle and
leveraging our studio's autocomplete as
the filtering mechanism
as we navigate to a particular help page
or call the function
for example one step of data processing
that occurs for all assays is the
transformation to a c disk atom basic
data structure
because of the function naming
convention we have chosen a list of all
available bds transformation functions
are displayed
and we can select for the assay of
interest focusing on the package
validation elements we also need a
systematic approach to how we map
package requirements
test cases and test code files
validation is a form of user acceptance
testing
where we have to show that for every
software requirement there was an
appropriate test successfully executed
the modular approach we use at sharp is
incredibly flexible
which has the development benefits i
will discuss later but it does require
some organization to track
in addition to enforcing a file naming
convention we also scrape these files to
generate a tabular display in the
validation report
which links requirements and tests
between these two implementations both
developers and validation report
stakeholders
are able to verify at a glance that
complete coverage exists
the last couple recommendations i have
address the topic of technical debt
you may be wondering why are we
splitting assays into separate packages
a couple reasons first fta guidance asks
us to revalidate the entire system when
one element changes
now change is expected input data
structures get updated analysis needs
drift
however an update to one essay type
should not introduce the appearance of
change affecting other assays
secondly from the user perspective we
need to put some conceptual structures
around processes
sure every data set will be converted to
bds but the definition of that basic
data structure will vary from acid to
assay
and we need to capture that distinction
in a manner that is easy to digest
what we also want to avoid is excessive
re-implementation
as we have expanded to multiple assay
packages we have identified utility
functions that can be shared and moved
into their own foundation package
we can enforce package code dependencies
through routine use
of the description file but the power of
modular validation means that we can
move the associated specifications
test cases and test code files as well
validation of the lighter assay package
with the new utility package
is simply compiling the r markdown
document without any need to rewrite
content
likewise when we need to add additional
specifications
test cases or test code to an existing
package an
updated validation report will add the
new child documents to existing sources
this has the added benefit of being able
to use a simple div to compare
validation reports
across package versions so i wanted to
take a moment to thank those who made
this work possible
especially the preceding efforts by
ellis hughes and the combined
contribution of the sharp p data
standardization team
future work includes formalizing our
validation practice
through a fuse org collaboration with
deliverables expected later in 2021
you